you know what McCarthy's first thing
that he's going to do now that he's
House Majority Leader you know what the
Republicans are going to do it's
actually pretty beautiful he already
announced it
I know the night is late
but when we come back
our very first bill
really peel the funding for 87 000.
maybe this is the chance right what do I
always say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
and the Republicans will probably fail
you I still believe they will probably
fail us but there is a chance here like
that's a great moment the guy comes in
right the first thing he says we are
going to get rid of 87
000 new IRS agents that's what these
lunatic Democrats were putting forth
that they want to make sure they can
find all of your money right they can
always find enough money to give to
Ukraine another 40 billion in that
bananas 1.7 trillion dollar spending but
they want to just find out how much
money you sent to your aunt on PayPal 87
000 agents to look into you they take
your money to pay people to look into
your finances and
you applaud it not you them okay so it's
a good start so what else can you do in
McCarthy and I'll I'll hopefully sit
down with him and just discuss this you
know what go after fauci go after
Twitter go after this Administration if
if this is your opportunity right now
all right I'm talking to you Kevin
McCarthy
this is your opportunity these 20 most
of them came around and did end up
voting for you you've got a little juice
right now if we do not have free speech
in the United States we have nothing
else we know that the administration
pressured Twitter to take down tweets
and to silence Tucker Carlson that is a
violation of the First Amendment someone
in the white house has to be fired and
you know what I bet you you could figure
out an argument that it goes all the way
to the top
foreign
[Music]